ce monsieur a failli vous reste plus
beaucoup de ceux à rabat du show les
gars fait pas trop froid l'ajustement
est rauque en profite aujourd'hui pour
me découvrir un peu de faire problème
3 avec le manque de cheveux aujourd'hui
et la pluie
[Musique]
poser la question est ce que le fait
d'être légèrement dégarni à cette époque
là on n'a pas trop froid qu'est-ce que
ça peut bien vous faire justement c'est
une question fort sympathique que je
vous pose parce que hausse intéressez
vous demande absolument pas et vous
venez souvent monsieur oui quand c'est
fini vous arrive vous faire faire une
régénération et oui mais ils allés
saccager et comment ça fait 12 ans 12
ans à 25 ans est ce que vous pensez
qu'il vient une cause précise
particulière d'après un toubib c'est la
fatigue
qu'est ce que vous faites comme
profession je travaille dans la
restauration
est-ce que vous pensez que ce soit très
positive ce traitement parce que on
parle beaucoup de produits on part de
différentes là j'ai dit et je risquais
rien pour espérer un hors du tout en
tout cas vous avez d'après satisfait
pour la star et et vous espérez étape
une très bonne vous espérez ah oui
j'espère la messe qu'il ya une
amélioration depuis que vous êtes un
traitement j'ai pas encore vu à quoi un
mois et demi je viens à peu près dans
ses souffrances en somalie pour
commencer à voir
c'est à dire qu'au bout de quatre cinq
semaines on devrait commencer avant un
résultat pas de coquetterie horreur la
simplicité sur des choses de la merde
sur le village et au tofu naturel se
dépasser ce qui est mieux et on avait su
rester plus longtemps que j ai la
reprise le succès féminins à ça
ça y fait un petit peu et se passe
évidemment pas cheap et ses pairs ne
fallait pas mon général ces phrases sont
bien les femmes sont comestibles
elles restent comestibles récurrence que
malheureusement elles sont toujours
avenante et disposés aux sollicitations
des choses je crois ça et beaucoup à
l'industrie des chapeaux
[Musique]